we are team top five for a whole month
we were trapped in the evil Dino Rob's
Dino dimension a place where we were
duplicated dozens of times eventually we
managed to escape but now Dino Rob is
sending his army to take us back
together we fight them off and hope to
ultimately take down this deranged
dinosaur the more we countdown the
weaker he gets this is top
so I took my pajamas test that I was
that he was a grass tank which is Brita
the first time I took it I was the
closest weather and so it was like it
kind of makes sense I guess but not
again hey so uh since you basically
missed out on all of Mario May we
thought some Harry Potter will be just
the thing to get you back into the
spirit into everything guys okay um let
me slip into something more Gryffindor
and I'll be ready to go teleporters
[Music]
that's fast Slytherin eh let's get
started shall we
[Music]
these are the top 5 best Harry Potter
movie moments number five
Dolores Umbridge is the perfect villain
she has incredible fashion sense the
best interior design and presents
herself as righteous when she really
would name a child if it meant power and
respect and she does just that
Albert is appointed to professor of
defense against the dark arts and in
order to discredit Harry Potter and
Dumbledore refuses the notion that he
who must not be named has returned
during the first class under her
tutelage Harry insists that the events
of Voldemort were all too real earning
him a one-way ticket to detention his
classroom persistence resulted in a
special new punishment Harry is told to
write lines with emerges black quill
which uses the blood freshly carved from
the back of the writers hand in lieu of
ink harry dutifully writes until a scar
forms during um bridges disturbing
assertion that harry knows he deserves
to be punished
the way the letters appear lagging
behind his writing and painfully etched
into his skin stuck with me and the cold
cruelty of this interaction really
illuminated the submissiveness Umbridge
expects of her students number four
[Music]
the Great Hall is arguably one of the
most eye-catching rooms at Hogwarts this
most important gathering area can
regularly fit all four houses of
Hogwarts students and its employees and
guests under a canopy of floating
candles and an enchanted sky ceiling for
meals all deliveries exams and pretty
much anything else they need but I am a
sucker for festive decor and where the
Great Hall truly shines is when it's
decked out for the holidays the sorting
ceremony sports lively house colors with
bountiful buffets and the sorting hat
front and center letting new students
take in the halls opulent majesty
witches and wizards are common motifs
even in the muggle world on All Hallows
Eve so you know Hogwarts goes all out
for their Halloween feast there's the
Frog choir that sings double trouble the
floating candles are adorned with carved
pumpkins and the food includes all sorts
of mouth-watering sweets
even the ghosts look forward to a
Hogwarts Halloween but Christmas is
where the Hall truly shines for students
who stay behind treats are once again
plentiful at the Christmas feast with
tall ornamental trees and snow falling
from the enchanted ceiling there's
something so specifically magical about
snowing indoors like you're living in a
snow globe they outdid themselves at
Christmas with the Yule Ball decor which
made the Great Hall like stepping into
an ice palace every detail from ice
sculptures to tiny potion bottles
perfectly lined the dance hall making it
unforgettable Oh to go to Hogwarts would
be a dream but send me on a holiday or
else why bother number three do Diagon
Alley
there's really got your quills your ink
it's difficult to keep from comparing
the movies to the books some characters
and locations just can't live up to the
expectations of what film is capable of
if they even made the final cut at all
the big exception to this would be
Diagon Alley after the secret entrance
through the leaky cauldron the scenic
cobblestone street was left straight
from the pages onto the screen -
perfectly introduced The Wizarding World
and shops overflowing with garnish lead
rests customers and kitschy magical
products from the family seeking
Hogwarts school supplies to the near
dwells that frequent the seedy
underbelly Knockturn alley the shoppers
of Diagon Alley showcased the lively
aura of the Wizarding haunt the quirky
architecture and rustic awnings remind
you that these are no ordinary muggle
storms children huddle with their noses
pressed against Broome boutiques and
more seasoned witches discuss floral a
coachman outside the millinery showed a
young wizard need a wand and
unparalleled customer service
Ollivanders is the place to go after a
quick stop at their vault at Gringotts
Bank to get some spending sickles for
that new Defense Against the Dark Arts
textbook you need because there's a new
professor again or autographs of famous
wizard authors on their book tour head
over to flourish and Blatz and take a
page or two home it's one of the most
well rounded locations the characters
interact with regularly thanks to the
atmosphere cultivated by each of the
design teams working in harmony how
could you not want to get lost and
explore every nook and cranny yourself
you almost can the Harry Potter studio
in London has a small walkthrough
version of the set among the other movie
sets and props and Universal Orlando's
Wizarding World has a Dagon alley that
has interchangeable shops and
attractions number two
not my don't issue makes
valiance Molly Weasley is a true
Gryffindor and a badass she's a
full-time mother of seven who loves and
supports all of her children even Percy
for some reason and nurtures a strong
bond with her eccentric husband that
love and support doesn't stop at family
though Molly readily opens her heart and
home to those in need
even when their space and supplies are
already stretched thin
she's a crafting Queen from repurposing
hand-me-down dress robes to hand
knitting personalized Christmas jumpers
her generosity makes even the loneliest
Souls feel welcome like all moms she
knows where you are at all times and
she's fiercely loyal and protective you
could have died after all molly is not
one to lie down and let anyone walk all
over her or her family
nothing showcases that more than when
she stands up to Bellatrix Lestrange an
incredibly powerful witch and ruthless
murderer but she steps in to protect her
youngest child and only daughter Ginny
this is far from an easy task for her
she doesn't swoop in and furiously take
care of Bellatrix in a single blow
but bravery is facing your fears head-on
she struggles to defend against some of
the oncoming jinxes but eventually
succeeds in casting conferring go
blasting Bellatrix to oblivion avenging
serious
Tonks Dobby and the Longbottom's while
ensuring the world was one Death Eater
safer and the number one best
harry potter movie moment is
[Music]
expecto patronum
with Harry only recently being reunited
with his Godfather the stakes are raised
when they are surrounded by Death Eaters
hell-bent on taking Sirius Black
back to Azkaban previously we saw that
they were a bit partial to Harry Potter
as well and because of his previous
encounters with them Professor Lupin
shows Harry the defensive Patronus charm
up until this moment Harry has been
unsuccessful with the spell but Sirius
his life now hangs in the balance
suddenly Harry sees his father's
Patronus across the water
and they are saved later in the film we
learned that James Potter is still very
much dead but it was Hermione's
time-turner that was able to place an
alternate timeline Harry in the right
place at the exact right time to cast
his own Patronus knowing that it was
possible since it had already happened
this mode is the culmination of all that
the film worked up to and the payoff was
great seeing Harry's Patronus was
perfect the wispy stag of life chasing
lays demons which matched his late
father stag was the perfect blend of
hope and heartbreak the life-or-death
suspense of Harry and serious situation
was what made such a lasting impression
the Dementors in this movie are truly
haunting their design and interaction
with the environment around them really
sucks the happiness and warmth out of
you in the best way
[Music]
what's good mix are amazing why would
you even say that dr. pepper something
weird to the doorknob guys whoa oh
trying to make her duplicate
[Music]
so glad you could join us
[Applause]
[Music]
you